I hate to do this to you but I think you
can help me pick up the slack on those
etchy sketches no problem
and shoot you pulling doubles
quick thinking yesterday with that
special talents thing I feel bad for the
guy I just hope he doesn't get wise well
he hasn't figured out he's a human by
now I don't think he ever will
[Music]
yes I figured out he's a human by now I
don't think he ever will
I think they're too small
[Music]
[Music]
you don't look so good buddy are you
okay I'll be okay I just need a glass of
water
foreign
sorry I can't ride with you the rest of
the way yet but this is where my dad
works well have a good time oh I forgot
to give you a hug oh I don't know Connie
I've never declawed kittens before how
many
eight
I don't know if I'm gonna have time
well all right just bring them by the
camper this week and I'll see what I can
do
I'm not gonna charge you just bring them
by and I'll see what I can do
excuse me
I'm here to see a Walter Hobbs
I'm Buddy the elf
hilarious
pop elf
from the North Pole from the North Pole
yes so you really think we should ship
them no I think we should take a thirty
thousand dollar bath so some kid could
understand what happened to a puppy and
a freaking pigeon ship them
yeah Mr Hobbs it's Liam intercom go
ahead yeah I think someone sent you a
Christmas gram
dad
all right uh let's get it over with
I walked all day and night to find you
you look like you came from the North
Pole
Santa must have called you oh yeah sure
he uh just got off the cell phone with
me
so go on
go on with what well are you gonna sing
a song or something or can I just go
back to work a song
uh yeah
anything for you Dad um
I'm I'm here with my dad and we never
met and he wants me to sing him a song
and
um I was adopted but you didn't know I
was born so I'm here now I found you
Daddy and guess what I love you I love
you I love you
ah
that was weird
usually guys just you know put my name
in the Jingle Bells or something it's me
your son Susan Wells had me and and she
didn't tell you and and and but now I'm
here it's me buddy
Wells
and Wells yes
Christmas cram I want one
I think we should call security good
idea
it's okay Walter's my father Well your
dad's busy right now okay I'll come back
later yeah you know you're not gonna
come back for a while okay you're gonna
go back to Santa Land okay yeah why
don't you go back to gimbals
Sam
my hey everybody
[Applause]
who the heck are you what are you
talking about I'm Santa Claus no you're
not
why of course I am oh you're Santa
what song did I sing for you on your
birthday this year
happy birthday of course oh
so uh how old are you son
you're a big boy what's your name and uh
what can I get you for Christmas don't
tell them what you want he's a liar
let the kid talk you disgust me how can
you live with yourself just cool it
zippy
you sit on a throne of Lies look I'm not
kidding you're a fake I'm a fake yes
how'd you like to be dead
huh sorry kidding
you stink I think you're gonna have a
good Christmas all right I like beef and
cheese
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I waited five hours for you why is your
coat so big so good news I saw a dog
today have you seen a dog you probably
have
how was school was it fun did you get a
lot of homework huh do you have any
friends do you have a best friend does
he have a big coat too go away
ow son of a nutcracker
[Music]
[Music]
oh no these guys are bad news
we better get out of here
you know what if we can take them okay
I'll start making as many snowballs as
you could
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man one got away snowball
foreign
[Music]
wow
where did you say you were from